hey y'all time for another movie
retrospective do it another Michael
Crichton show this is what happened you
remember a couple weeks back when we did
that other Michael Crichton movie looker
that friend of the show and patron Rob
sent to us and when we were talking
about that and actually when we were
watching looker Tom confused some
aspects of lookers plot because he's
like oh I saw this this is the one with
Gene Simmons she's oh my god a light gun
and yeah and the killer spiders so it
turned out that he was actually thinking
of this movie yeah which is called
runaway runaway yeah the light gun was
from looker but the other stuff was from
this movie runaway and Robson is the
copy of this one as well so thank you
very much for your generous movie giving
yeah yeah in looker um there was a light
gun yeah you could point it somebody
press a button and it was shoot out of
pulse like skin it would scramble your
brain it would give you a black out for
a second somebody could whip your ass
[ __ ] white but you didn't know you
didn't know that you blacked out you
thought that time was jumping forward
yes that's an interesting idea I think
it was based on up on a real concept
probably not something that you I don't
think you could actually do that but
it's based on a concept for a non-lethal
weapon that the military was probably
interested in one time because that I
read a lot of stuff that they were
interested in but this one this movie
did have gene Simmons in it with a
special gun but it was a heat-seeking
missile or was a missile that somehow
locked onto an individual person it was
no it was heat signatures because
everybody is heat signatures different
presumably so you have to like know that
person's heat signature and then like so
it's like a smart bullet essentially but
is he also heat-seeking yeah they fire
it and it would come after you you could
see it from the missiles point of view
you know they had the rocket I've you
looking for the person just kind of cool
effect it was a very cool effect yeah
it was the movie I remember when it came
out this movie was old you know I mean I
mean it was I thought it was old when I
first saw it yeah it came out before
Robocop I believe this came out in 1984
okay so maybe it wasn't before Robocop
think Robocop might a little bit older
than that
I thought Robocop was 86 or 86 maybe
what I could be wrong about that
I remember being impressed at the time
but you look at it now and you're in it
it's very much very you know it came out
the same year as terminator yeah and it
really kind of suffers in comparison
yeah
terminator was a lot better and
terminator really changed the game yeah
when it came to this kind of movie but
it still was a good movie and when they
were making this one they had no idea
terminator was gonna come out was gonna
come out and just like pummeled every
other sci-fi right into submission yeah
terminator that's it sci-fi movies had
to be really on point yeah and I mean
this one like I said and I talked a
little bit about this on the looker one
too because this is also written and
directed by Michael Crichton and he
really does seem to now this one in
particular yes like a lot of his stories
kind of seemed like technological
cautionary tales although this one he
said what the even though this is what
that's what this ended up being as well
I he said that his concept for this was
just kind of to make like an old school
like cops and robbers type of movie but
then give it like a slightly futuristic
veneer yeah it's about a cop who's in a
special unit that just destroys runaway
robots yeah and they got agricultural
robots and then I guess everybody has I
mean it's basically like Rosie from the
Jetsons like everybody has you know
robots in their house that like cook and
like babysit and like help the kids with
their homework and everyone's just like
he's like Michael Crichton has said that
he deliberately like didn't say when
this was supposed to be said even though
if you watch it it's very obviously 1984
yeah but it's like he he was like saying
oh well I imagine that it was just like
a year or two in the future
everyone had just got really comfortable
with the idea of having like these
domestic robots like everything done by
robots and the robots in this are really
their michael crichton ii they are very
michael creighton using a printer it
doesn't like everything looked like
because the renner are a stereo
well the one that was like chasing
Kirstie Alley around issues in this too
but the one that was chasing Kirstie
Alley around I'm like is that just two
slide projectors on top of yeah yeah
that's kind of what it looks kind of
looked like made a [ __ ] like that it was
and like you could kind of tell which in
a way is like I don't know it's like
that projectors this is like yeah oh and
that one that one like that came to I
don't remember what the function of that
one robot was I guess like when all the
cops came and they were like cleaning up
the crime scene or whatever or no it was
I think it was a bomb disposal and that
was very clearly an overhead projector
like lapped on top of something else
like some cart with like a bunch of
bells and whistle on it which like I
said it's like you can look at that now
and be like oh the 80s but it's like
really charming kind of I remember back
in the day when I saw it back in the day
and I think when I saw it I saw it on
VHS so it was probably out for at least
a year
yeah ready it didn't look that bad yeah
it wasn't that much out of place but
like I said Terminator coming out
changed the whole [ __ ] game this is
basically across the storyline and the
concept is cross between Blade Runner
and Terminator instead of hunting down
replicants you got to hunt down these
damn domestic robots they're not much of
a threat that's the problem yes they
were just not a [ __ ] threat here's
the thing it's like okay now like I said
you don't need a special police unit to
do this Michael
yeah michael creighton said he just
wanted to make like a cop movie but with
robots that's just that like a couple
years in the future without any like big
whiz-bang like kind of like oh it's the
future type of thing like it's just bit
like domestic robots it's just very like
commonplace so the thing about it so Tom
Selleck plays like the main character
and I guess he was like a quote-unquote
real cop at some point but because he
has you know like the hero weakness
where he has like vertigo and I guess
like he couldn't chase
like up a really tall building and that
guy like got away and then later went
out to kill a bunch of people so he
feels really bad about it and he got
like essentially demoted to this
specialty police unit that all they do
is go track down runaway robots that
like start malfunctioning the thing
about it though how they establish this
because it's like so it's him and then
he gets a new partner he's played by
Cynthia Rhodes who most people will
probably recognize from dirty dancing
because she started out as a dancer she
was at a few other movies in the 80s -
so she's like all jazzed about it cuz
she's like all into computers and
everything so she thinks is gonna be
super fun and then Tom Selleck's
characters like [ __ ] it this is like the
most boring thing ever but um the funny
thing is how they establish this police
unit it's like so I guess one little
agricultural robot whose whole job is
like picking caterpillars like off of
corn or whatever yeah and so it starts
going haywire and like making some like
zigzaggy [ __ ] like all over a cornfield
and it's like so they called this police
unit out and they come there in a bit in
a helicopter like with all and there's
two of them and basically all they do
it's like you think if there was like
this special take unit they would have
some like high-tech equipment where they
could like neutralize it from far away
or so no they just like have to go jump
on it yeah and like turn it off I'm like
why didn't the farmers do that though I
said I was thinking every pretty much
most of the the robot missions that he
goes on as a cop I mean a kid could just
kick the thing over that's what I was
one of you had a laser but that was
about it a lot of the stuff in that you
know it's just they're not that the
robots are not threatening yeah not
until they be like the very final scene
when he has to fight some you know the
little spider robots it even knows or
not they just got wind up toys the the
the highlight of this movie Tom Selleck
did a pretty good job yeah you're good
enough he did a pretty good but the
highlight of the movie was gene Simmons
gene Simmons is really the the what you
want to see what you want to watch whoo
I heard got the part he didn't even have
to read for it I guess he just came into
the casting I was looked and stared
really hard Michael Crichton with those
like creepy with that
he stared that he has and he's like
you're hired he played a good bad guy
had him all dressed up in a suit with
his hair short any played an assassin
like a corporate assassin trying to
steal these damn computer chips that
were corrupted that you could you you
could have them put into people's robots
and hijack them I forgot the reason why
I wanted to do it because I well see
that's the thing I just work a lot too
and I was like thinking okay because
here's the thing so after the silly
scene was like the agricultural robot
where you know they just jump on it and
turn it off which is all they had to do
the etiquette of the cops in the
helicopter come out there so then they
get a call that a robot has flipped out
and killed I guess it killed like a
woman and a baby was still in the house
yeah and another person too
yeah this is really the best anti robot
scene and yeah I mean the and it and
it's kind of like the outfit that he
wears on the cover yeah he goes in there
to go save his [ __ ] he it puts on a
[ __ ] sharks it's a shark say yeah
well yeah I could understand it though
maybe they know but I was like hey man I
used to watch a male shark shoot a laser
that kind of acted like a laser but I
think it I think it had a sound effect
when you pull the trigger laser gun but
I was thinking why the hell do you need
a laser gun for that he could just use a
37 magnum revolver to get rid of that
things all was a piece of plastic that's
what I figured plastic robot but yeah so
apparently this is a domestic robot and
it is gone I was watching lists like
this other review of this and like the
guy cracked me if they were British and
the guy cracked me up because he says
this robot goes a bit stabby and then it
goes a bit shootie yeah yeah so he like
knife didn't like shot like a couple
family members and then there was a baby
in the house a Tom Selleck had to like
go in there and neutralize the robot
look before he gots the baby and stuff
so then he's a big hero and all this
other stuff so there's that whole thing
so then it almost becomes like I said
like a cop like a murder mystery type of
thing because when they take this killer
robot apart like after they've
neutralized that they find that it
hasn't actually broken but there's like
a chip in there that looks like it was
put in
they're on purpose that overrides
because apparently this is the first
homicide that's ever been committed by a
robot and it overrides its programming
and essentially makes it into a killer
robot and like I said you find out that
gene Simmons is to blame that he's like
making I guess he's made like
manufacturing these chips to put into
robots so he can assassinate people at
will but I'm not really sure what his
endgame is just because he's just evil
or is there because it seems like oh
there's a bunch of money in it because
Kirstie Alley he was doing it for a
corporation for what I remember yeah he
was like a hired guy he's corporations
just wanted those chips that's how I
remembered it yeah because Kirstie Alley
would like was trying to steal him and
then she was gonna sell him like cuz she
was his ex-girlfriend or something it
has a lot of the problems of a film of
the of its era and you know even
Crichton talked about the edits were
slow yeah so because by modern tastes
it's the editing is kind of slow you
kind of lose track of what the hell's
[ __ ] going on and sometimes the plots
that are not ready to plot but the
motivations of certain characters gets
kind of muddied yeah a little bit kind
of forget about what somebody wants and
and things aren't didn't have the
ability to illustrate what they were
talking about a lot of times so some
character would say something and go in
one in one it go in one ear out the
other
you're like huh what do you say I [ __ ]
it they're not guys show us what he's
talking about anyway so kind of like
they did that a lot in 50s movies where
they're just sitting around and offices
talking you're talking about something
you were never gonna see they did that a
lot in the eighties yeah and you know
it's it's probably due to budgetary
constraint yeah but they will also but
here's the thing they wouldn't play to
the strengths that the movie had yeah
and the strength that the movie had was
gene Simmons in that [ __ ] rocket gun
there should have been a lot of that
because the book they were like that
they were like heat-seeking missiles
like a roll-on bullet and there were
smart bullets like when you take them
out like it could find a particular
person and it would turn around corners
there should have been a lot of that and
there could have been a lot of action
scenes riffing on that aspect of the
movie
these damn heat-seeking missiles that
really could have been your damn movie
now I did like the extended car chase
scene at the end where gene Simmons was
trying to get because remember Kirstie
Alley alley had that like tracker thing
in her purse and didn't know and then so
all these little essentially little
drone robots were like going through the
traffic and like going under cars and
like blowing him up and [ __ ] like that
so I thought that was actually really
well done they had enough there they
could have edited it and you would have
ended up with a better movie with Jane
gene Simmons as the main baddie and it
would have been like an action flick
similar to kind of like I come in peace
I ever a Dark Angel yeah I mean that was
the same movie just has two different
names yeah and I think I think it would
have been a better movie at the time
because this thing I remember it it was
instantly forgotten you know it was just
something you rented once away yeah and
you talked to your buddy
yeah and you see that rocket that it's
you know the rock like the chase around
the corner you ask good idea it's the
only thing you remembered about it and
robots bikers I didn't really remember
those but yeah I remembered the robots
that shot acid which I mean that's the
thing like that's another thing where
I'm kind of like gene Simmons in this
movie is clearly like a mechanical and
like computer genius and I'm sitting
there going okay well he can make these
chips that override like the robots
programming so chase can like kill
whoever you want he's invented like
these heat-seeking missile bullet things
and it's like then robot spiders that
shoot acid seems a little a convoluted
way to kill somebody will they say
instruction robots weren't they working
on the construction zone that they that
the final fight happened I thought you
were going to rock them there with that
maybe I don't remember see that that's
that's a problem it gets kind of
convoluted you're not really sure cuz it
things are not clearly shown yeah it in
the 80s you had still had a lot of
talking and not showing yeah terminator
changed all that
yeah and we showed you the [ __ ] like I
showed you the future this movie really
suffered for being released a little bit
before terminator came out also like a
bunch of like I think a Star Trek the
search for Spock came out the same
about this there was like a bunch of
other like really good movies or sci-fi
movies you know and what you have like
Ghostbusters and stuff like that - which
is more fantasy but it's like you know
so all of these movies came out so this
one it's like it's a good movie it's
just you can see why it got forgotten
about a little bit just because it
wasn't for a sci-fi movie it wasn't real
like cutting-edge enough it wasn't you
know it didn't have a lot of really the
cop stuff and like that was the best
aspect of it I thought it was when
you're saying it's a good movie I'm
gonna say it depends him it was a it was
a well-made movie for the time yeah with
the standards of the time it's just that
everything was changing it was changing
rapidly yeah
and when you say it's a good movie had
good acting yeah good it had the kind of
edit most movies had at that time it was
just like I said it didn't play to its
strengths and it could not foresee what
was gonna come out that year yeah that
was the Frog yeah yeah so and the movie
was forgotten because of the new stuff
that came out I had actually never seen
this heard of it I saw this one and I
saw looker yeah and the only things I
remembered were those damn guns over the
years yeah and I confused the two yeah
because they weren't real standout to a
14 15 year-old boy yeah and that's
really kind of what the audience was
that's who would go buy this kind of
[ __ ] that's it was renting it yeah you
know I mean that's who was renting this
at the blockbuster if we even had
blockbuster then I think we did I don't
even remember having blockbuster until
the 90s I think we might have block we
had movie gallery I think I had we had
one I think was called Showtime theaters
Shogun yeah there was a Showtime video
or yeah I think there was like a smaller
chain yeah sometime show bit no show biz
was pizza that was like it's a knockoff
Chuckie Cheese this was something we
rented but yeah it's worth watching just
to see the way people thought in the
eighties
you know what I think this amused the
[ __ ] out of me okay so Kirstie Alley was
in this was this before after she was in
the Star Trek thing I think it was after
it might have been slightly I she was I
know cute it was but I think she this
was before she was on cheers though I
think thanks so it's hard to say but
I've never watched cheers I hated
television even back then I mean I
wasn't a big fan but I knew she was on
it like she replaced that what's that
blonde chick that was on it but um I
think this was before she got real
famous with cheers so she was on this
and I think she was nominated for a
Saturn Award for this which is like the
sci-fi you know or words even though her
part in this consist pretty much mostly
of yelling yeah she's yelling and
they're the funniest scene in this is
the scene where they introduce her
because okay they set up that Tom
Selleck and his partner played by
Cynthia Rhodes have kind of like a
budding romance type of thing going so
they set that up a little bit so then he
has to go and save Kirstie Alley because
she's been trapped in an office by one
of the copy machine robots who's
shooting a laser at her even though like
I said it's only about two feet tall and
you can probably just kick it over like
on its face so the laser can't get you
so as I don't know why she can't just
like walk around it but so she's trapped
in the office and the first thing like
Tom Selleck comes in there and he's like
looking through this like glass window
or wall or whatever like a door the
first thing he says about her is well
she's quite attractive or something like
that and I'm like Lady culture like that
seems a little like not very
professional I remember dudes being like
that I think he just did that like to
piss off his partner because he knew
that like she had a crush yeah just so
they could have her go [ __ ] I
don't know you might be reading into it
like I just what no I just it just seems
so random you know what I mean like for
a cop to walk in and just be like the
first thing you know you think maybe
he'd say something like oh she got
herself in a pickle or she was like
commenting on the scene before going we
would haughty that's just yeah that's it
but that's the eighty that's the 84 I
remember I am just it's like [ __ ] like
that right but not a jam like I said not
in a work situation yeah yeah
but it was the movie situation though -
that's what I mean it's just about like
not it out I think in a work situation
it was like that at work - well I don't
because just a few years later you know
I mean when I was in certain time when I
was in Michigan [ __ ] you know in high
school I had took a part-time job at
like Perry's drugstore and [ __ ] and it
was below the bunch of [ __ ]
knucklehead kids I could [ __ ] around
and said that kind of [ __ ] I can just at
work
yeah damn look at that booty but they
were knucklehead kids though naughty I'm
not a grown-up cop I would have been the
same probably I mean it's like I was
like wow that's kind of unprofessional
but yeah so like I said it's this is a
very Michael credit I like look or
better this one like I said it's kind of
more a standard mid-eighties sort of
action movie like with a technological
yeah but not super high-tech it's not
there no time-travel there's nothing
like that like I said that you know like
in looker where the one you know the
janitor robot which just looks like a
little box like on wheels with a little
panel that opens with little arms like
all of the robots are kind of like that
except for the spider ones that are you
know that are spider shape but they're
not very big and it just seems to me
that that's what I was saying about
James you know now that I think about it
if I knew how to make like a killer
spider robot with the shoot acid I
probably would just because I know
they're not very practical I think the
movie is an important movie in terms of
the this is this is a movie that's
showing you definitely the end of an era
yeah you couldn't do this anymore yeah
all right
terminator have changed all this there
was a missed opportunity in this movie
and I'm gonna say that that was gene
Simmons gene Simmons was a credible
character in the movie credible bad guy
I don't he could have been a bad guy out
of a Robocop movie you know the main
heater Bennet you fit right in yeah I'm
in a real
got warrant only had to do was stare and
scowl at you you [ __ ] your pants you
could put you could have put him in a
lot of movies yeah I gotta put him at t2
I think he actually was in a few more um
maybe some kind of like lower budget
movies and with didn't he he played a
villain on Miami Vice - am I remembering
that wrong I don't know I mean I didn't
see a lot of I didn't Miami Vice but
it's like I was pretty sure I even
either saw it or heard about him being
only one I remembered yeah I think he
was in a couple of other things you see
I could see him playing against you know
jean-claude van damme at a time at that
time yeah imagine him going up against
sensei I was just gonna say is since a
Steven Seagal but Steven Seagal when he
when he made ok movies yes go did have
some good movies you know like under
siege under siege 1 & 2 I liked it ya
know yeah and they're dumb but they're
like yeah what's the mark for dad some
of I think was mark for death or yeah
they all sound the [ __ ] same under
the mark for death and killed gun game
wakes up out of the coma that's the one
I was told that was about a coma [ __ ]
[ __ ] everybody up we were just we were
thinking about him because we subscribed
to this other like movie review channel
[ __ ] case cinema and it's just like this
this British guy rags on and he just
like and he just shits on like crappy
movies all the time he's just there like
drinking he likes him he does Joe and he
does like a lot of Steven Seagal movies
because Steven Seagal apparently I mean
he's got the worst movies of them all
has just like keep like makes like forty
bajillion movies a year that go direct
to DVD I don't know like how could he
possibly be making money on any of that
he does have his own fan base you know I
mean and you and they just see whatever
you don't spend a bunch of money on one
of them which clearly they don't he
knows what his fans want imma given that
he knows her hands want that's what he's
doing I can't watch this [ __ ] I can't
either
it's a problem with the problem with a
later latter day it's a golf since a
calling since a yeah more than I'm not
gonna call him a martial arts fraud okay
Aikido is a martial art this is just
whether or not Makita actually works and
whether or not he actually uses I don't
want to get into that we did another
show called Bushido and you can you can
you can I talk more about to go in the
Bushido show you can watch that one but
the problem with his movies is that it's
not that they're bad is that they're
boring
gosh I do feel like if if a bad movie is
[ __ ] entertaining it's entertaining
well yeah that's what I'm saying
if you're gonna make if it's gonna be
bad you might as well just lean into it
and make it as ridiculous as possible
yeah Birdemic right like Birdemic course
that isn't wildly entertaining I think
that was an accident though they know
but it was just like it was clearly made
by aliens nano 8 is another one that was
it was by accident they weren't leaning
into it yeah just the way it was but it
was funny though it was anyway the
incompetence yeah latter day anything
beyond like [ __ ] 93 ish okay 94 which
that was a long time yeah there's a long
time you don't want anything Steven
Seagal after that the one that the one
that Johnny [ __ ] case was reviewing that
we just watched was attack force was
that what it was called they're all cops
a weird thing about it was he said that
originally it's been supposed to have
like aliens and [ __ ] in it but then
later they decided to make it not aliens
but people enhanced by some kind of
weird club drug yeah so they had to go
back and redub all of the dialogue yes
and he's not a sensei's voice yeah yeah
and it's like and you could tell like in
the clips that he showed and stuff like
that I'm like oh my god that looks so
bad but I gotta tell you
Seagal is an amazing man
it's an amazing man the stories about
him you know he's a man of legend that's
true he is a legendary character man
legend cop martial arts master of the
world I'm gonna say Pierre well we don't
know he did have some Russians Russian
girls with him just all this [ __ ] you
hear about it
shots ooh master can find breast cancer
very you know you can bite fine breast
cancer within 5 feet wherever he goes
check you for breast cancer say that
[ __ ] if you don't know what race he is
he's a different race depending on what
what voice he's using oh my god I can't
believe it I can't believe like [ __ ]
old dudes think they can still get away
with that I checked thankfully my scan
things that still might have a pony tail
well in the attack force movie it looked
like I couldn't tell if it was a pony
tail or like a mullet because it was
very it was really fluffy back there he
recently went to Russia and whipped like
50 60 do russian soldiers asses in front
of [ __ ] you know and you've just
whipping them all in front of a whole
stadium Putin watch it you just let the
kumite yeah I know they got it on videos
they got it on video
they can watch it's a deep fake it's
it's like I think it's a setup you know
it's it's a demonstration yeah okay it's
a dip like here I'll just like to swish
my yeah yeah and they go follow exactly
it's a demonstration of the power of
Aikido in sensei
yeah he's doing it with cheese yeah it's
kind of cheap for two balls no touch
knockouts and stuff yeah that's exactly
probably yeah
all right so but yeah so if you're into
like Michael Crichton this is again a
very Michael Crichton a um type of movie
it's like a lot of them are um it's like
I said I like look or better just I I
liked that concept kind of better in
that concept
was actually a lot more um you know
prescient than this one because this one
like he said you know this was for
experts only yeah you can't like [ __ ] on
it for the year that it came out but
it's like you know Terminator came out
that year and it's changed again kind of
just got completely like overshadowed
and forgotten about because of that but
the acting is good it's like it's pretty
entertaining gene Simmons is you know a
good villain and this is the end of this
movie style you get to see Kirstie
Alley's bra yup like that if you're into
them you're not gonna see sci-fi movies
like this ever again after this year no
probably not
I mean they make a lot of forgettable
sci-fi movies now too but you know
they're not they're not quite like this
you can't get away with this but this
time like you could in the 80s make end
of an era making robots out of like
slide projectors and yeah alright so
again thank you very much Rob for
sending us the movies he sent us 30 days
of night - I think yeah we gonna watch
it so we're still gonna watch that I saw
it a while back that it's like a really
good movie so yeah thank you very much
and we will see you next time check it
out Michael Crichton's